simulation is an important tool in the
analysis of probabilistic phenomena for
example suppose that X Y & Z are
independent random variables and you're
interested in the statistical properties
of this random variable perhaps you can
find the distribution of this random
variable by solving a derived
distribution problem but sometimes this
is impossible and in such cases what you
do is you generate random samples of
these random variables drawn according
to their distributions and then evaluate
the function G on that random sample and
this gives you one sample value of this
function and you can repeat that several
times to obtain some kind of histogram
and from that get some understanding
about the statistical properties of this
function so the question is how can we
generate a random sample of a random
variable whose distribution is known so
what we want is to create some kind of
box that outputs numbers and these
numbers are random variables that are
distributed according to a CDF that's
given to us how can we do it well
computers typically have a random number
generator in them and random number
generators typically what they do is
generate values that are drawn from a
uniform distribution so this gives us a
starting point we can generate uniform
random variables but what we want is to
generate values of a random variable
according to some other distribution how
are we going to do it what we want to do
is to create some kind of box or
function that takes this uniform random
variable and generate G of U and we want
to find the right function to use
find AG so that the random variable G of
U is distributed according to the
distribution that we want that is we
want the CD F of G of U to be the CDF
that's given to us so let us see how we
can do this let us look at the discrete
case first which is easier and let us
look at an example so suppose that I
want to generate samples of a discrete
random variable that has the following
PMF it takes this value with probability
2/6 this value with probability 3 sixths
and this value with probability 1/6 what
I have is a uniform random variable
that's drawn from a uniform distribution
what can I do I can do the following let
this number here be 2 over 6 if my
uniform random variable falls in this
range which happens with probability 2
over 6 I'm going to report this value
for my discrete random variable then I
take an interval of length 3 over 6
which takes me to 5 over 6 and if my
uniform random variable falls in this
range then I'm going to report that
value for my discrete random variable
and finally with probability 1 over 6 my
uniform random variable happens to fall
in here and then I report that random
variable so clearly the value that I'm
reporting has the correct probabilities
I'm going to report this value with
probability 2 over 6 I'm going to report
that value with probability 3 over 6 and
so on so this is how we can generate
random samples of a discrete
distribution starting from a uniform
random variable
let us now look at what we did in a
somewhat different way this is the
x-axis and let me plot the cdf of my
discrete random variable so the cdf has
a jump of two over six at a point which
is equal to that then it has another
jump of size three over six which takes
us to five over six at some other point
and that point here corresponds to the
location of that value and finally it
has another jump of 1 over 6 that takes
us to one at another point that
corresponds to the third value and look
now at this interval here from 0 to 1
and let us think as follows we have a
uniform random variable distributed
between 0 to 1 if my uniform random
variable happens to fall in this
interval I'm going to report that value
if my uniform random variable happens to
fall in this interval I'm going to
report that value and finally if my
uniform falls in this interval I'm going
to report that value we're doing exactly
the same thing as before with
probability 2 over 6 my uniform falls
here and we report this value and so on
so what's a graphical way of
understanding what we are doing we're
taking the CDF we generate a value of
the uniform and then we move until we
hit the CDF and report the corresponding
value of x it turns out that this recipe
will also work in the continuous case
let's see how this is done
so let us assume that we have a CDF
which is strictly monotonic so the
picture would be as follows it's a CDF
CDF's
are monotonic but here we assume that it
is strictly monotonic and we also assume
that it is continuous it doesn't have
any jumps so the CDF starts at zero and
Rises asymptotically to one what was the
recipe that we were just discussing we
generate a value for a uniform random
variable we move until we hit the CDF
and then report this value here for X so
what is it that we're doing we're going
from use to X's so we're using the
inverse function the cumulative takes as
an input and X the value on this axis
and reports a value on that axis the
inverse function is the function that
goes the opposite way we start from a
value on the vertical axis and takes us
to the horizontal axis now the important
thing is that because of our assumption
that F is continuous and strictly
monotonic this inverse function is well
defined given any point here we can
always find one and only one
corresponding X now what are the
properties of this method that we have
been using if I take some number C and
then take the corresponding number up
here which is going to be FX of C then
we have the following property
my random variable X is going to be less
than or equal to see if and only if my
random variable X falls in this interval
but that's equivalent to saying that the
uniform random variable fell in that
interval values of the uniform in this
interval these are the values that give
me X's that are less than or equal to C
so the event that X is less than or
equal to C is identical to the event
that U is less than or equal to FX of C
so this is how I'm generating my axis
based on use we now need to verify that
the axis that I'm generating this way
have the correct property have the
correct CDF so let's check it out the
probability that X is less than or equal
to C this is the probability that U is
less than or equal to FX of C but U is a
uniform random variable the probability
of being less than something is just
that something so we have verified that
with this way of constructing samples of
X based on samples of U the random
variable that we get has the desired CDF
let us look at an example now suppose
that we want to generate samples of a
random variable which is an exponential
random variable with parameter 1 in this
case we know what the CDF is the CDF of
an exponential with parameter 1 is given
by this formula for non-negative XS
now let us find the inverse function if
au corresponds to 1 minus e to the minus
X so we started with some X here and we
find the corresponding u this is the
formula that takes us from X's to use
let's find the formula that takes us
from use to X's so we need to solve this
equation let's send you to the other
side and let's send this term to the
left hand side we obtain e to the minus
x equals 1 minus u let us take
logarithms minus x equals 2 the
logarithm of 1 minus U and finally X is
equal to minus the logarithm of 1 minus
u so this is the inverse function and
now what we have discussed leads us to
the following procedure I generate a
random variable U according to the
uniform distribution then I form the
random variable X by taking the negative
of the logarithm of 1 minus U and this
gives me a random variable which has an
exponential distribution and so we have
found the way of simulating exponential
random variables starting with a random
number generator that produces uniform
random variables